you
The Walking Dead returned this week to
bonkers ratings but before we get into
that if you haven't watched let's look
at some zombies
okay maybe I should have given some sort
of parental warning there or something
i'm not sure you know can I just got
upsets me the most about that clip is I
went up for one of them and I can't
believe that that woman was casting or
even so she said well it was connections
she knew somebody at the studio uh
anyway the walking dead came back the
premiere out rated sunday night football
which is Cano yeah let's look at some of
the ratings no I'm kind of showing the
season one premiere had 5.4 million
season 27.3 season 39.9 and season four
16.1 why any network show got 16.1
million yeah they would be absolutely
thrilled what is and what like what
would a normal hit show get on a network
do you think I have no idea I mean if
you get 10 million now on a network show
you a pretty good shape i think big bang
theory's the number one comedy it gets
probably like 20 million something like
that so I mean 16.1 is huge wow I've
seen point what it's like a third of the
audience that all in the family is to
get so it's a huge hit nowadays yeah
isn't that something well there was only
so many channels back soon yeah so now
yep yeah so does this just show you how
televisions changing and that these
other channels like AMC are actually
just making better stuff than you know
in our old school minds we keep thinking
that CBS ABC and fox we're going to make
all the good stuff well I think when you
when you open up a marketplace generally
get more competition and people you know
kind of rise rise to the top you know or
tump some do anyway um I mean I love the
stuff that's on cable I don't have time
to watch everything that I want to watch
I was watching the walking dead for a
while and I was so into it yeah and all
of a sudden at one point like I imagined
it might happen with porn I just like
when I've had enough you know and it was
just like again you know the zombies are
getting stabbed in this blood coming out
and the people are eating each other I
mean it's just I guess I guess the
storylines and the characters stopped
grabbing me but apparently yeah they're
grabbing a lot of people and those
zombies like they just like look they're
lining up on purpose to get slaughtered
it's like so does being a zombie also
lower your IQ a couple of points like
they
your brain is affected is it you just
keep walking to the food I just want to
feed and it's all is that it yeah you
just wanted cement for though it's a
metaphor for the Tea Party anything well
yes you're a lot of the public I think
that you just kind of keep walking
towards the disaster even though it's
inevitable oh I like that what does it
say that it's out rating football that's
I mean a Chanel passing I think that's
great you think that something I am I
have never been a football fan yeah I've
just never grasped the game I like I
love baseball I really like basketball
I'm not a football fan and I'm not a I'm
not a fan of the fans of football hahaha
I think that that's really what does it
for me funny and I'm just like tired of
like I'm just tired of people like
thronging to it and a lot of people i
like and love really like football yeah
but you know I do it for me and I liked
it something superseding it i really
like wow that's something is uh is the
walking dead the best commercial that
the NRA could ever have because in that
world you need a gun and every time I'm
watching that I'm thinking this is sort
of why I believe guns should be legal
because I have far more belief that
we're gonna have a zombie invasion or an
alien invasion then the government is
gonna come get me you are you buying my
dress you bought you you believe I think
a zombie invasion is more likely than
the government coming to tell me how you
were ruined with all you know all these
pesticides all these the things were
eating you know so you think about
logical undead yes sort of like I am
Legend kind of stuff and I'm gonna need
a gun to to save myself crazy you know
what if things get that bad the way they
are in that show I don't want to be
around because all my whole day is
getting up and killing zombies I just
don't want it yeah I was like oh god
like another day yeah where's the life
quality I mean I'm working I'm with you
Jimmy isn't it though wouldn't you free
yet all right they should be using this
and saying look zombie oh I don't think
you're making a serious point I'd be
alien invasion yeah what about the alien
invasion we're gonna need weapons if
some [ __ ] goes down no I think we're
actually go the other way I actually
think we have a bigger chance
to the government coming and taking us
away especially now with the you know
they can put you in jail without any
charges forever ever did it already they
can totally tortured our own soldier
chelsea manning right for a year
tortured um president knew about it
didn't give a [ __ ] and so I I be more
I'd be more afraid of the government
than of zombies what if the government
like calls you in for an email and then
they just like correct the punctuate
they're like Jimmy you're the only one
still using salutations no one uses
salutation I still do i still use no
Sally seriously I try to say hello oh
yeah I'm a very professional in my name
at the bottom I do as well throw me an
email yesterday you wrote XO at the end
kiss okay well sometimes sometimes it
has a special day is it for certain
people but yeah now I thought it was a
little under the roomba report brought
to you by Cooper calm they've got up to
seventy-five percent off cat and dog
treats toys and more you can get another
twenty percent off using code RR the
link is right down below click it and
make your pet happy